hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi video
everyone's asking where the hell is he
he's in there and they have a plan for
him so I'm gonna explain what that is
there is a new round of the Star Wars
giveaway it's for to IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the break
so everybody's seen the plans for the
next couple of Star Wars movies we know
about the Skywalker Saga films and then
we know about the next anthology film
after rogue one the Han Solo film there
has been no mention of an obi-wan film
there were announced plans for a really
down and dirty gritty Boba Fett movie
that josh trank was going to make there
was a teaser they were going to release
for it that they had already worked on
it was happening around the time they
were revealing rogue one at celebration
last year but because of the mess with
fantastic four josh trank scurry r went
on the toilet they just put Boba Fett on
the shelf but the thing here is that
there's no obi-wan in there everybody's
wondering where's the obi-wan spin-off
film next to Luke Skywalker next to Han
so like why wouldn't you do one you know
this talk of a Yoda film but obi-wan
seems like it'd be an easier slam-dunk
but supposedly there's a really
important reason for that
the Saga films themselves like the
really big saga films have a plan for
obi-wan Kenobi that will play out but
won't be completely revealed till
episode 8 in episodes 9 fully till
episode 9 so the theory is that the
obi-wan character is very important to
some of the bigger reveals of the new
films in that if they were to do a
spin-off film for him explaining what he
did during that time between films and
we begin to spoil some of the big twists
and turns of the saga films so think
about that what's one of the biggest
reveals of the saga films we haven't
seen yet rey and her origin a lot of
people even Daisy Ridley the actress
herself feels like Episode seven kind of
explained who her parents were without
going as far as say like holding up a
family photo saying you know mom dad
daughter so you have Rey touching the
lightsaber it's showing her all those
visions of the past they actually
brought you and McGregor into the studio
to record new dialogue
for that scene he just screams out you
know Anakin no on the most basic level
it's a scene that just meant to show her
the history of the lightsaber itself
what happened to its wielder Anakin
Skywalker but it's also intended as kind
of a warning this could happen to you
too as well if you're not careful the
force is very complicated it just
depends on the choices that you make so
later when people went to McGregor and
sort of talking to him about coming back
to the new Star Wars films he said he
was very open to it and if you look at
him he's actually taken very good care
of himself he's slowly ageing him into a
very age-appropriate obi-wan Kenobi
think about how old Alec Guinness was in
episode 4 ellen mcgregor isn't going to
be that old for a long time so were they
to do an obi-wan Kenobi spin-off film
set between episode 3 and episode 4 he
would be like a slightly younger version
than the Alec Guinness obi-wan Kenobi
but you can see how he'd be an older
more mature version than he was in
episode 3 it's just the idea that
they're holding off on obi-wan in the
current films right now the spin-off
films because he's going to be much more
important later Star Wars has big plans
for obi-wan Kenobi much bigger than they
let on just think about how much secrecy
is surrounding episodes 8 in episodes 9
right now
they're not even going to show off the
teaser supposedly until next spring
maybe not even till March at the
earliest so I know a lot of people are
wondering if Ray might be related to
obi-wan Kenobi I think the films have
effectively told us that she's not a
Skywalker but the new Saga films are
effectively a Skywalker saga so she
would have to be someone relatively
important to the Skywalker family so the
next step on that ladder would be to
make her a Kenobi it would either mean
that she's related to someone else and
obi-wan Kenobi's family so she shares
blood with him so she could be related
to Kenobi without actually being the
daughter or granddaughter of obi-wan
Kenobi
but if he's literally one of her
progenitors there's only a couple people
that we know about that he actually had
romances with and only one of those
people is still part of the Canon in the
Clone Wars he actually had something of
a romance with Satine it was only
implied but she'd be the most likely
person for obi-wan to have a child with
and if you never watched the Clone Wars
all explained satine's character she's
really interesting she was featured
in about 13 episodes of the Clone Wars
which is a lot all across the middle in
later seasons many many episodes and
she's been referenced a lot during Star
Wars rebels recently as well as things
that happen around her life and death
during the Clone Wars I never planned on
killing you but I will make you share my
pain remember my dear Obi one
I loved you always
so when present day she's dead she died
at the hands of Darth Maul during the
Clone Wars but there was a long time
between when obi-wan first met her and
when she died there were many many
episodes that featured her so there is
plenty of room in there for this so just
to explain a little bit more about
Satine
she was royalty on her planet the
interesting thing about Ray's name is
that it is Spanish for King meaning that
she has this sort of grand destiny ahead
of her like she's meant to be the
beginning of this grand new dynasty of
the Jedi Order
Dave Bologna actually said some funny
stuff and this actually makes you think
a little bit more about Rey being extra
special kind of flowing from her lineage
is this a teen was modeled after Cate
Blanchett when she played Queen
Elizabeth in Elizabeth and Elizabeth the
Golden Age so they're basically modeling
this character after one of the most
powerful Queens in English history Cate
Blanchett obviously very beautiful as
well - but can you just imagine Rey
being the daughter of Cate Blanchett
inside the Star Wars universe the recent
rebels hat tip if you haven't been
watching rebels they totally gave her a
shout out but it was more of a reference
to the Clone Wars and the stuff that
Darth Maul did when he encountered
obi-wan and her during their adventures
this is actually the dark saber
underneath her picture
get away from that is that a lightsaber
indeed yes but not like any that you
would know if you're Mandalorian friend
was here she could explain it to you
so when Darth Maul says you're
Mandalorian friend could explain this to
you this is basically the dark saber
which is a huge thing in Star Wars Canon
but it showed up when obi-wan was at
Mandalore with Satine who was
Mandalorian royalty so you just start to
think about the idea of the dark saber
and you're getting really excited but
then to that the idea that rey might
flow from Mandalorian heritage which
makes you think about the Boba Fett film
that they have sitting on the shelf
right now - so don't get too sad about
that don't worry Boba Fett Mandalorian
things will come back - the Star Wars
universe eventually but for those of you
that have been complaining that the main
films have not been referencing rebels
or the Clone Wars enough of the animated
series the stuff that's still canon
because all that stuff still is canon we
could see the dark saber pop back up in
the main films but also the idea that
rave blows from a dark past just like
Luke Skywalker flowing from Anakin
Skywalker who'd became Darth Vader and
just to bring it back around to actual
physical obi-wan in the new films really
like the way to bring him back is just
like they brought him back in Episode
seven as a voice as a force ghost like
you see obi-wan in the original trilogy
because even though they only really got
into it during the end of Clone Wars
where Yoda learns how to become a force
ghost he is essentially immortal now in
when Luke Skywalker eventually dies the
same thing will happen to him so even if
they move on past the Skywalker family
in another trilogy after Episode nine
because there is talk that they won't
focus on the Skywalker family after
episode nine which I'm totally fine with
they can still invoke Luke Skywalker in
the Skywalker family via force ghost but
there's been so much talk about them
maybe doing an obi-wan trilogy not just
a single obi-wan film but a new obi-wan
trilogy after the new films I don't know
if they'll go that far but there will be
a lot of obi-wan in the Star Wars
universe still in fact I'll say without
giving away spoilers there are some Obi
one Easter eggs some visual Easter eggs
as well as some
verbal shoutout reference Easter eggs in
rogue one so in that just look out for
multiple different types of ob1 things
happening so I'll explain that when I
post my Easter Egg video later this
weekend so what's going to happen is
I'll post some new DC later tonight then
I'll post my rogue one Easter Egg video
on Saturday
so we'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Jeffrey Gibson
you and the imax gift certificates I did
start a new round at the beginning of
this so I'll announce the winner when I
post that Easter Egg video so get hype
rogue one was a lot of fun I'll post my
non-spoilery review at the end of this
and don't worry they will start dropping
some Star Wars Episode 8 stuff pretty
soon well you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my non-spoilery
rogue 1 review and you can click here to
learn all about the fastest speedsters
on the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody
what's that bot I'll see you guys
tonight me me me me
[Music]